um now as you were sort of alluding to
before and the international
mathematical olympiad is kind of
embodies this idea
you're someone who knows and relishes
the power of a good
problem you know a problem is not just
um for the sake of getting an answer in
fact usually
in many cases the answer is not really
the point it's it's what you had to
you know the acrobatics you had to do in
your mind to get to that to devise a
solution
and so that's why one of the things i
love that you do is you pose these daily
challenges and you post them up online
for people to participate in and that
was actually something which got you a
lot of attention uh
sort of you know er late 2019 i think it
was
um because through posing one of those
challenges you actually came up with a
result
about quadratic equations and trying to
solve quadratic equations
um now for those of our viewers who you
know some of them are a bit younger
they've not met quadratic equations
before
um but these objects these mathematical
um items they've
fascinated humanity for millennia you
know the babylonians the ancient greeks
egyptians chinese indians all over
my question sort of as an introduction
to you without getting into too many of
the nitty gritty details is
why have humans been so interested in
these quadratic equations why are they
so useful
oh i think the reason why people have
been interested in quadratic equations
is because they're hard in the sense
that
what i mean is there's some easy
equations like
three x equals six you just undo
the three you're gonna multiply by three
then unmultiply this divide that's not
hard
or x plus two equals five just
unplus the two that's reasonable but now
the quadratic equation was strange
because it's very hard to
undo x squared plus x plus
6 equals zero how do you undo you don't
and so i think people have always been
fascinated by whatever is at the fringe
of what they can barely what they can do
and what's just on the fringe or what
they can't do
so i think that's why that's been there
and also of course they've been
practical
i mean if you had a field for for
example and you know the perimeter of
the field and the area of the field
and it's a rectangle well then how could
how would you figure out the dimensions
that turns out to be related to
quadratic equations too
got it so there's kind of these two
aspects to it right it is there is this
practical sense
but they're also sort of delightful
objects of their own you know i guess it
sort of speaks to the fact that
um you know newspapers uh around the
world they were often published you know
uh crossword puzzles or sudokus or
things like that and we actually there's
something in every human being that's
like i like to wrestle with something
that's
a little bit interesting a little bit
challenging so as you were you know
working on this
daily challenge of yours that involved a
quadratic equation
it came about that you devised this new
method and we won't go into
the nuts and bolts now because people
can go and search that up and it is
fascinating because it's part of what
the majority of people around the world
will have learned some way
to solve a quadratic equation may have
forgotten it by now but it's still
kicking around somewhere in their memory
what i'm interested from your
perspective is how did it feel
as you were devising a new method and
when you described
sort of when you discovered wait a
second this is not something that i've
met before what was the sensation going
to you at that point
oh my gosh when i came up with this way
that i had never seen before i basically
fell out of my chair
because i my job is to teach right so in
some sense and i also coach olympiads
right
so my job is to know as many of the
methods
that there could possibly be and as that
rebel i always love doing things in
different ways
so i have actually always been trying to
find different ways to do anything just
for the heck of it
and then when i found this way i just
thought how come i've never
seen this before because i can tell you
how it came about
the reason is because i was trying to
find a way to explain to very young
people how to solve quadratic equations
and i had first experimented with this
with some elementary school kids
actually
and i tried to explain it to them with
the traditional method which is based on
completing the square
and that's when i found out that for
first-time learners especially young
students doing a lot of
algebraic manipulations with lots of
formulas is actually
difficult compared to let's say for us
teachers if we're used to manipulating
so much you're like of course you expand
the brackets like this
but for younger people the expand the
brackets like this
we just learned it right right so then
so then i was trying to come up with
some different way to maybe try to teach
this in a different way
and i found out that you could solve one
particular quadratic equation one way
and then it just occurred to me you can
solve all of them that way and then i
just got super excited
because for us as i said what we care
about is finding new ways to do things
by the way in the end i found out it
wasn't new at all babylonians had done
this
this way maybe babylonians didn't use x
and x squared
because they didn't know what variables
were in the same way so they didn't
really do it this way
but the heart of the strategy was based
on how babylonians figured out the
dimensions of a field
given the area and the perimeter so it's
like we sort of knew this technique for
3000 years
but it didn't make it into any textbooks
and it's really funny because there is
this story of mathematics being this
immensely
international and historical discipline
because
in some senses it doesn't matter whether
you are speaking uh
english or babylonian or any other
language
the mathematics underneath those
realities and patterns and numbers
are in a real sense universal i just
think that's fantastic
so i just wanted to come back to
something you said earlier you know i'm
thinking about everyone who's watching
um who finds math mathematics you know
inscrutable and opaque and
you know we're using words like
beautiful or or elegant when we think
about this particular solution method
what is it that makes a particular way
of solving a problem
elegant versus some other method that
you might find it doesn't have to be
quadratic equations
um how would you describe the difference
between those oh
i i'd say if you use what we're trying
to do with math is we're trying to look
at things
from different angles and sometimes when
you look at it just from the right
perspective
everything lines up and fits together i
actually feel that's the main value that
math often gives some people think of
math as what you do when you calculate
out answers but to me that's just the
routine part
the interesting thing is well i could
either do a lot of brute force that way
or if i looked at it this way it turns
out that everything is symmetric somehow
and it all fits together
yes i think it's fantastic and it's it's
like you said i remember
a quote i read once that you know
computation
is to mathematics the way that your
spelling
is to literature it's kind of like well
yes that's that's a part of it but it is
a very very small
narrow part of it isn't it it's kind of
like the the precursor or the necessary
thing and where
interesting stuff is happening is
actually elsewhere so i think it's
really
quite obvious why you know you would
head down into this rabbit hole of
mathematics professionally now
i'd love to talk to you about what life
has been like as an academic because
and this is something which most of us
again look at from the outside now
we should point out as well that not
only do you work in a university but
you've had
quite a university career i mean you
studied first at cal tech the california
institute of technology
and then you did some study in the uk at
cambridge university
and before coming back to pre to the us
for princeton
um now you've gone to the other side of
you know
um being the student to now being a
teacher and and also
sort of researching and that kind of
thing could you give us a sense like
what's a normal day like for you
um is there such a thing as a normal day
in the life of an academic
ah so this is interesting because a lot
of times people will think of what does
a professor do and if you look at the
movies the professor is this bumbling
person who
is supposed to teach income like
incomprehensively that's not exactly
what professors are supposed to do
at the university where i work what we
do is we have a blend between
teaching of course i'll do some of that
later today still
as well as the responsibility is to
contribute something to the knowledge of
humankind
and that's that's what research is about
right the main point is
to create something that outlasts you if
that makes sense
uh but by the way different universities
have different ways of looking at this i
mean some places might be more
conservative and the way you do that
might be
discovering a new res a new method in
math
and explaining why it works that's like
a theorem
and a proof but there might be other
other things that you could do to leave
a lasting impact and i really enjoy
working at carnegie mellon university
which is where i
am because it's one of the most
entrepreneurial type of universities i
don't mean in terms of starting a
business
i mean in terms of thinking is it quite
open-minded in terms of what does it
mean to make impact
and in fact it's in that broad lens that
i actually usually operate
these days the sorts of activities that
i work on unfortunately every day is
actually different
but that's because as i've mentioned
i've been here for 11 years
i have a i built a certain track record
here of doing lots of very strange
things
that might sometimes leave some impact
maybe like that quadratic method or
something
or other things that i work on these
days if they happen to overlap let's say
into healthcare or
managing or managing pandemics but the
main objective is to think
what are the kinds of things that you
can do that will of course educate the
students we have here
but also leave some lasting impact on
human knowledge so speaking of
that lasting impact on human knowledge
you know your particular area of focus
is
discrete mathematics and combinatorics
now i remember studying some discrete
mathematics at
university myself and you know sort of
looking at the subject outline before i
chose and thinking
discrete mathematics is this like
secretive like
mathematics but of course this is a very
different kind of disgrace to do with
whole numbers can you tell us a little
bit about you could you give us like a
thumbnail sketch of
the fields that you particularly work in
oh sure
so i think that if i if i think about
discrete mathematics a lot of times
that's bundled in with the study of
networks
and the study of networks there are lots
of networks in the world one of them
might be the internet which is what
we're using to have this call right now
but another kind of network might be the
network of human relationships of who's
spending time with who
and you could imagine if you watch some
of those movies sometimes they draw this
big
chart on the wall which is that these
people are around each other those
people around each other and so on
now the reason why there's a whole area
of math around that is because if
somebody just gave you a network
what would you do with it you know it's
actually very messy a network is just
that i might have a billion people and
some of them interacted with some other
people
is there any head or tail that you can
make out of this mess and in network
theory you'll realize that there might
be some things that are useful
for example it might be useful to
consider for a person
how many people are they connected to
that's actually called the degree
of a node but the notions of oh if you
have a network where the degrees are
very high
what kind of consequences might that
have turns out that that means that
in such a network there are more ways to
go from like a node to another node
this is of course not really rigorous
but i'm saying like heuristically
the higher your degrees are meaning like
if on average every person has
more more connections out then it's
faster to kind of get from someone to
someone else
but these kinds of notions you can turn
into even writing proofs
for example a typical a famous result in
network theory is
if you have i wonder if this is actually
in your book already but somehow if you
have any six people at a party
and you make the network of who is
spending time who already knows who
turns out that there's always going to
be some three of them who already
this person knows this person this
person does this person and this person
knows that person
or if you can't find that there'll be
some three who they've never
met and they've never met and they've
never met i i'm almost positive you put
that in your book
because it's famous you're absolutely
right po
i'm talking about network theory and
that minimum number of six um i think
the chapter in my book was called six is
a crowd
um but that's it is a very
counter-intuitive result i mean there
are plenty in there that within network
theory that are
immensely related um to you know
applications in our world which we will
get to
shortly um but i think it's really clear
from what you've just said that
you wanted to do more than just research
and teach within a university context
and you were talking about
um carnegie mellon and it's sort of
entrepreneurial attitude
um so i wanted to talk about xp for a
minute e
x p i i this is something that uh you
founded a company organization
um and it's actually for those of you
who are watching at home i think you
should go and check out
xv.com there's a sort of sermon to life
or resources there
but it's actually the name of it itself
i remember puzzling over it and then
realizing
this is actually something which is very
personal to you
could you just very briefly explain
where the name comes from
oh so xp was a website that i
and actually a fellow student at
carnegie not fellows in one of my
students at carnegie mellon we had this
idea that
you know if you could make a website to
try to explain lots of concepts
in high school math and science where
it's not just let's say
one person's explanation but like all of
the different best explanations we could
find
put into one place then this could be a
useful resource because we had learned
that people were often doing their
homework by googling for things
so we said if you're using google to
find resources google's not the best at
sorting the educational resources
so can we just make one free website
where we have all of these
different explanation videos that were
found on youtube i think that's how a
lot of our team found you by the way
and you know all of all of the most
interesting ways in the world put them
there
for a reason because not everyone by the
way learns from videos some people like
to learn from words
and so we we actually had an objective
of let's have videos let's have
written explanations let's have pictures
okay but we had to come up with a name
for that website
and you know we tried lots of different
things there's one problem on the
internet these
days a lot of the names are already
taken but you want something short right
so
we thought five libraries would be great
we thought about different kinds of
word prefixes and suffixes and xp
sounded nice from the experience exp
experience but then what clinched it was
when we realized that you can spell it
e-x-p-i-i
and then it would have a double meaning
you seem to be very sharp in figuring
out what this double meaning is
it's the most beautiful equation in
mathematics it's the exponential of pi
times i so the name of the website is
actually
experience expis pronounced xp
it's experience points in many people's
video games but the way it's spelled is
the x ex exp is the exponential of pi
times i euler's formula e to the power
of pi times
i and then plus one turns out to be zero
and this is the most beautiful equation
in mathematics
i am just so delighted hearing that
explanation from you and that
particularly that double meaning i think
is delightful but actually
you know you talking about uh e to the
power of pi
i plus one equals zero euler's formula
his identity like you were saying before
that was actually the very first time
that i encountered you there was a
there's a
sort of well-known video of you um
speaking in front of a blackboard and
i'll give you an explanation for this
delightful result
and i remember thinking hmm i reckon
this guy and i would get along really
well and that was many years ago and i
was right
now um tell us more about like you said
you're the founder um you gave us this
explanation
for why you created it sort of curates a
lot of these resources because
um as you pointed out you know search
engines out there they do their very
best to try and you know
collate you know based on who links to
who and who which results are most
popular and so on
but you're obviously trying to do
something quite different in the way
that you've structured things
um i'm interested in how people have
been using it because
you know xp is not new now how have you
been finding that actually people have
been getting on and what benefits
they've been getting from it
yeah again the main purpose of making
that website was just to deliver
resources to people that they would
possibly want and so early on well not
really on middle in the middle of our
progress we did a lot of this user
research of asking high school students
how do you try to do your homework
that's how we found out that everyone's
googling everything
so in fact the vast majority of the
people who drop on xb.com
just come in because they were googling
something and there's probably around a
thousand topics
in high school mathematics mainly
algebra
and high school science mainly biology
where the top result in google
will actually be our page and that's not
because we paid google anything we don't
have any money to pay google anything
but it's because when our team is making
those lessons
what we what our what our objective is
is go and check everything on google
our goal is to deliver what the student
wishes they could get
in one go you know what i mean it's like
we know what are all the free resources
on the internet for this one topic in
mathematics
or science how do we make what the
student would go to and say you know
what
i'm really glad that this came because
that's exactly what i wanted
that's perfect it's sort of a one-stop
shop right now
i'm really interested because that is
not the only thing that's on xp and one
of the things that you and i have talked
about before which was so
immensely exciting to me when i first
heard about it was um project
spark this is a little bit different
could you explain
to our viewers what's project spark
about what's the point of it
i have this crazy idea that it i know
actually it's
funny i'm talking to you about this
because it seems like you have the same
crazy idea but i
have this crazy idea that somehow
everybody could learn mathematics
if maybe the way that you look at things
is different if we don't need to think
of mathematics as frightening you don't
need to think of mathematics as
something that you can't do
in fact if you think you can't do it you
can't do it and and so
the goal of this project spark was is
there a way to help
help make mathematics something that
more people can
embrace and maybe could we explain
concepts in math in ways that are
different from the usual
po on a blackboard explaining something
could it be maybe done in the course of
a video of somebody trying to
catch the bus and well there you go the
pythagorean theorem tells you how much
how much distance you get to save by
taking a shortcut but
that's actually one of the videos that
we made but we ultimately were just
trying to
take the way that you normally do
education but maybe put a very human
and entertaining spin on it in a way
that's genuine in a way that people can
uh can gravitate to so that they can see
themselves
in the in the in the in the mindset of
somebody who can do
math or science and then is also having
a great life because of it
that's fantastic i'm so excited by what
xp's achieving and it's very much like
you said
um my heart aligns so much with your
mission so i i think you know all power
to um the work of you and your team